so you definitely get up to a lot of
physical Kinks and you use them but
you're using them to achieve
psychological head spaces the most
common things were things to do with
anal then another one was golden showers
people are quite enamored with and what
was the feet good old feet number one
probably
hello and welcome to this episode of
extraordinary lives the podcast brought
to you by ludbible I'm Ben Paul Jones
and we're joined today by Eva oh welcome
Eva thank you for having me so for
anyone who isn't aware of who you are
would you mind introducing yourself
I am Eva oh as mentioned and I currently
work as a dominatrix I've been in the
sex industry as an escort
brothel worker massage parlor worker and
a few other things for over a decade
okay so it's a fascinating industry we
met you previously on a different video
we did and uh it's something that we
felt would be interesting to explore
more especially the dominatrix element I
think is something that people have
impressions of through popular culture
films and TV but maybe don't know
exactly how it works but before we get
into it could we talk about you a little
bit you know where you grew up what your
childhood was like you told me a second
ago that you'd like to remain mysterious
but what can we know about Evo
mysterious I don't know I think there's
enough information and exposure of me
out there that's not so mysterious
anymore but how I grew up
um I was born in Southeast Asia to a
very mixed family and partly English
also and we traveled a lot from my burst
so everything from Southeast Asia
Australia Europe mostly
and it did something to my voice as you
can see it's kind of from everywhere and
I was very lucky to have all of those
influences and somehow I ended up here
with you and as a child were you an
outgoing person were you shy
hmm I don't know how I would describe
myself even now I think on one hand
maybe shy is never the word but I don't
need to be the center of attention and I
think that was the same then I think
I've always been interested in
observation
and I was happy to insert myself if I
felt excited by it but happy to sit back
also
observation so people watching and yeah
yeah yeah
maybe even more so you know how those
people like to sit at cafes and look at
people going by almost don't do that I'm
more like to see the detail and I guess
what age did you find yourself becoming
interested in and look throughout this
conversation
um if I use any terms or words on how
people like to be described please let
me know but what age do you find
yourself becoming interested in sex work
when I first entered this industry I was
naive and I didn't even understand that
it was sex work
when I was 27 I went for an interview in
this BDSM dungeon and I had and
I had come to the end of a probation at
the most luxurious corporate job that I
had ever been offered and I was over it
and so I looked up this term that an ex
of mine had mentioned the word
dominatrix I had the idea of this woman
in leather and standing in some sort of
independent position but I didn't have
any particular clue it was just me
following a crumb because I knew I knew
I wanted to do something different or
even just for a little while and so I
thought let's Google this I found a
space I went in for the interview and
the first question they asked was have
you ever been in the sex industry before
and I naively said this is the sex
industry
so what did you think it was I wasn't
exactly sure
just something different and exciting
something to do with power and something
to do with the psychology of playing
with power which it is and which it is
mostly but because it interacts with
people's sexuality I consider it a part
of the sex industry and I realized that
now yeah so you said you you know you're
in a corporate job beforehand and also
27 feels quite late to me old no I mean
I'm a lot older than 27 but just going
but you know were you what do you mind
me asking what were you doing before
this then what was this kind of
corporate life that you had I started
off uh in my early 20s and went through
a huge progression of different things I
think that I was always looking for some
sort of creative stimulation and I was
definitely very idealistic maybe still
so and that just brought me through a
lot of different options so I started
off as a performance artist I had a
ballet background moved into production
moved into the advertising world for a
little bit uh worked at the UN for a
little bit uh in Refugee research did a
design research stint had a sustainable
design agency and then moved into
strategic Consulting wow yeah and so I
was very mobile and happy to be open to
life and information and experience but
it reached a point where I wanted to do
it for money and that was when I
realized that money often equated
um
squashing of my ideals okay so it was
hard to be paid for the thing that you
really wanted to do well I was
fascinated with the research that I was
able to do but I wasn't enamored with
how they were using that research okay
right and I suppose that explains the 27
bit but do you agree with me that 27 is
late to come to a realization about that
sort of career or do you think that's
average based on the your experience I
think some people go to their death not
knowing what might suit them okay yeah
so you you followed the Chrome as you
said from an ex-partner who'd mentioned
dominatrix he was joking and I find out
we're quite close okay it was like that
was that was a joke but okay you took it
okay so you go for the interview and
they said have you ever worked in the
sex industry and presumably you said no
I said no is this there no okay and then
what happened and then they went
why don't you start and we can see how
you are in two weeks that's the only way
we'll know basically it was maybe a five
minute interview yeah and they were
great they were right they'd seen so
many of me before I guess so I stuck out
the people who worked there I was
enamored with the job I was motivated I
wasn't earning anywhere near what I was
earning in those first few years
compared to what I was earning in
corporate but it was engaging enough for
me to Slug It Out and the
um do you mind me asking like when so
when you first started at that job is it
um
it
what what do you do what happens in
those places
um well essentially the job is
clients come in with specific ideas
about how they want to have an
experience usually around fetish often
around power play and you are there to
carry out this fantasy scene for a
moment in time an hour maybe more
and
what happens within that is according to
what they are interested in but a lot of
the times when you approach a dominatrix
as opposed to maybe a fetish escort
you're looking for that power exchange
somebody to take charge of how you might
emote how you might move through space
for a little while okay that's
interesting
so can you tell us about your first
experience you know when you first
joined that BDSM dungeon um
I guess what I find interesting
about it as a concept is like
how do you know what to do like you know
I said to you earlier we we've we've met
Danny D who's a porn star and like it's
very clear what you have to do as a man
in that situation well to be good at it
I'm sure is you know complicated but as
in how did you know
what you've just described sounds like
there's it needs quite a high level of
empathy psychological reading and
understanding yeah you know
um
it feels like you could upset someone as
much as make them happy oh yes okay
do I know what I'm doing
it's uh 10 over years in and I still
feel like I have to be careful and that
I'm learning right yeah
um it's amazing to be able to toy with
people's minds but like you said it's a
dangerous place
um
I observed
I did end up sessioning on my own that
first day which I am amazed about but I
was mostly observing how other people
were doing it I was invited into their
sessions I was helping them do certain
things and I just picked things up that
way but I mean in the first few minutes
when I entered on my work day I sat down
in the waiting room with all the like
there were maybe three other people on
shift that time there was up to 25
sometimes but uh there was three other
people 25. yeah
obviously they had been told to watch me
event now I realize and one of them said
to me so have you worked in this before
no are you into Kink at all no so why
are you here
and I thought about it and I said
I think that something about the
psychology really fascinates me and she
said that that's going to be the hardest
thing to learn so that's good that
that's the start of it yeah so you
definitely get up to a lot of physical
Kinks and you use them but you're using
them to achieve psychological head
spaces
can you expand on that a little bit for
us so let's say just first very simply
bondage say you're coughing two hands
hands that are normally mobile used
um legs that usually can take you
somewhere you're cuffing them you're
putting people in a vulnerable position
when normally they have such Freedom
they're trusting you they they feel
exposed they feel captured but yet they
have a trust so they get to experience a
sense of extreme vulnerability but in a
space of caring and so there's like a
thrill but there's also a surrender
to howl they really want to feel
comforted so there's a lot of things
that are going on you use these leather
binds but
essentially you're you're moving
somebody's mind and heart
and do they know that when they come in
and ask a lot of them don't think about
it but they have a sense okay they have
a sense I don't think I think a lot of
people don't go through life critiquing
why they might be drawn to something
they just live in the emotion of it and
I'm not there to say that they need to
think about it I'm there to do a job and
if I understand my job more intricately
I can do it better
so on that first day when you went in
and you were observing yeah like how did
it feel did it feel anxious or exciting
or what was the feeling
I
I was growing up I was going through so
many different environments I didn't
understand anything but change and
adaptability and new experience so now I
realize that the low level of adrenaline
doesn't need to happen all the time but
at that point it was just a norm for me
it was so much challenge especially from
the other dominatracies there was just
like almost an onslaught in terms of in
terms of the questions that they would
have in terms of how they would watch
you in terms of the
you know it's it's a bunch of very
opinionated creative
people in a tiny little room like almost
vying for the same clients it can be
quite competitive intense and their
frustrations can come out in all sorts
of ways and so it's a very intense
environment
not even talking about the sessions
it was great but it was it was great it
was very I mean even now I work
independently right and I see a lot of
people who start independently but they
take so much longer to understand the
job and the possibilities of the job
whereas because I was sitting there 25
different opinions different lives
different things to draw upon all you
had to do was sit there and listen and
see how they reacted to things and that
just opened your eyes to okay maybe I
shouldn't do that maybe this is a good
idea this is another option for me it
taught me so much about the job and I
still draw on that today and is the so
what you described a minute ago about
the hands being bound and the Fate being
bound
um sounds psychological is it also
sexual or sometimes sexual or always
sexual or doesn't you know how how does
that aspect work because I think the
majority of people who like myself who
are a bit unclear on how that industry
works the impression is that people go
there because they want to get off yeah
yeah and I think a lot of the times
people do but I mean what is getting off
you know is it like an escape from your
drudgery is it a sense of euphoria that
you're missing is it a moment of
connection is it a moment of pleasure
that you don't allow yourself
it's many things
so it wouldn't have to always be
connected to like uh
a base level of sexual gratification
I mean love a base level of sexual
gratification but its sexuality is such
a key to so much more of who we are so
sure we go to get off but that means so
very much
to me at least
okay and how long did you stay there at
that um the first BDSM dungeon yeah
until they closed about a year after I
joined they had been in the business for
40 years wow they were over it okay
their property for four million dollars
and you know they could have you know it
would have taken more time to make that
and they were towards the end of their
career anymore wow well that the the
place it was held in they sold or the
actual business the No No the just the
profit property oh my God which may have
come with a brother license I think that
it's become a brothel now so that's an
interesting point you bring up so um the
brothel license so was that is a BDSM
dungeon legal in the UK so this was in
New South Wales Australia ah where sex
work is decriminalized okay therefore
you have a lot of
licenses support systems ohns staff
coming through I gave I had a business
number I was a sole Trader registered
with them they paid me as an independent
contractor oh wow yeah it was great you
can have so all this support all this
security and safety and environment like
that and is that different to here in
the UK yeah I mean I never worked
commercially like that at all here but
it looks a lot more difficult and
clandestine and
yeah and people get their bank accounts
shut down and wow yeah it's just it
seems a lot more abrasive and violent
for people's well-being
okay
so with that first one that you worked
out for a year
um
do you mind me asking like what kind of
cost is involved for somebody who wants
to visit a place like that so sessions
um
were priced by content and we kind of
kept to a similar scale within those
walls even though we were independent
contractors and at the end of the day we
could have charged whatever we wanted
but generally it was 150 Australian
dollars for half an hour of foot worship
which was considered easier lighter
play all the way up to 600 for an hour
which included full service which is
penetrative sex and it could be more
harder plays so things that end up
leaving marks or that required a lot of
equipment or or labor intensity when you
say leaving marks is that on the client
or the dominatrix So within that BDSM
establishment a lot of the workers would
switch actually so they would do
submissive roles and domination roles
okay and so that that closed after a
year and did you stay in what age did
you arrive in or at what point did you
arrive in the UK like how long how much
longer did you stay in Australia did you
go anywhere else beforehand well I only
just moved here about five days ago
days ago
completely okay covered and family and
things like this oh okay
um but
I was in Australia for quite a few years
right yeah so did you did you know at
that point that you know you were like
okay this is me this is what I want to
do now did was there a point when you
realized that or was it a slow
progression because I guess what I'm
ultimately building up to asking is
do your parents not parents but do your
family know what you do and was there a
point that you sat them down and said oh
by the way because because your previous
jobs were quite
I don't know it was things that would be
traditionally they sound like things
that would be seen as traditionally
quite successful and hard to do ballet
and research have a LinkedIn profile
yeah sure right
LinkedIn profile jobs yeah although a
lot of Doms have LinkedIn profiles so
that they can do uh reference checks
okay
but uh it took me seven years to tell
them
I mean I was traveling a lot with
clients of mine and I would just say I
was doing
what I was doing all along but I know
that my mother knew she just knows but
I did I didn't know how to tell her yeah
in terms of
when did I know that I would just be
doing this forever I don't think I'm a
forever kind of person I think I'm
always open to shifts
but at about the seven year mark I
realized that not being open with
especially my mother who I'm very close
to
it was detrimental for me it made me
hesitate in my day-to-day because I was
considering others opinions of me when I
didn't need to and she was kind of the
Crux of that for me I felt like if I
could tell her then I would be more at
peace with where I was and how I could
learn how to communicate that in the
world
and did you going into talking to her
about it how did you think she'd react
I was prepared to be disowned oh yeah
she's pretty Christian she teaches uh
Bible study oh wow works at a Christian
School
[Laughter]
she definitely played the combustion
card more more than uh the Judgment card
when it came down to it I planned a
whole trip we were going to go to her
favorite like City and I brought my
family out paid for everything and it
didn't end up telling them what happened
was that they left and I texted in the
family group I'm staying behind to work
and she said oh what work is it and I
said
professional domination so it was
WhatsApp oh wow it to to everyone at
once uh it was just my parents okay and
um she said really and then she went to
the private chat okay uh give me some
time I said do you have any questions
she said uh give me some time I'll come
back to you and then we like just acted
like normal whatever for a month that's
amazing way to do it though actually
just to digest yeah like most people I
think in situations where they've been
told something like that would dive
straight in wouldn't they but to have
the presence of Mind say give me a bit
of time to think about this yeah yeah
she's an incredible person yeah and then
after a month or so she came back and
and I took her out another trip okay and
as soon as we were alone the questions
came
uh what are your motivations what are
the clients motivations what does the
interaction look like what does the
interaction look like when you're not
together like do you do you feel like
it's fulfilling do they feel like it's
fulfilling how does it impact their life
like she was just like all right I want
to know and within half an hour after
that she was joking about it yeah wow
yeah she's she's got quite in mind I
really were you able to be honest in
your responses like what do the
interactions look like were you just
completely open I didn't go too much
into the sexuality yeah aspects of it
yeah
but to be frank I guess I live in the
psychological aspects mostly anyway so
maybe it was more authentic than not and
now she asked me how work is and I'm
very shy
okay okay
but it's an open conversation okay
this is Ben pal Jones we're just going
to take a break from today's episode to
talk about one of our sponsors better
help this show is brought to you by
betterhelp how much time do you spend on
yourself in an average week so easy to
get caught up in what everyone else
needs from you and never take a moment
to think about what you need from
yourself but when we spend all of our
time giving it can leave us feeling
stretched thin and burned out therapy
can give you the tools to find more
balance in your life so you can keep
supporting others without leaving
yourself behind
therapy is something I've used several
times in my own life I think sometimes
we think it has to be for huge events or
massive changes but I like to just use
it every couple of months or a couple of
times a year check in on myself if
anything's feeling like a struggle book
a few sessions talk myself back up visit
betterhelp.com minutes with today to get
10 of your first month that's better
help
h-e-l-p.com minutes with now back to the
episode
and obviously you've said earlier
earlier that sexuality is very Broad and
um I guess the industry is quite broad
too was was the industry something you
were interesting it's in exploring or
was dominatrix the thing that you were
only interested in
[Music]
I realized okay so do I think about
something and think that I want to try
that I don't think I'm so pointed I
think I get a little sense of something
and then I'll dip my toes in and then
see if it suits and then see how it
looks even more I think that's more how
I work rather than saying I will have
this goal for better or worse and I
had this archetype in my head of this
woman in leather and then I got myself
into this dungeon and it worked out
really well right I just had a thrill
and an engagement that I didn't get
before then
and sitting in that waiting room with
all the other workers they would talk
about their lives and there a lot of
them were working at brothels a lot of
them were doing escort work and I
thought okay I'm here this is a resource
let's just try this and so I looked for
an agency an escort agency and I went
for an interview
and the first one really didn't work out
they tried to send me on a like a tour
so that means that you're traveling out
of the city as my first job so I would
have been booked on my own in a hotel
room it's just and I just thought no and
so I got a hint from a makeup artist on
a shoot for the escort agency and she
told me about a more reputable agency
and I contacted them and that was they
were lovely they eased me into it they
found a client that was working focused
first and yeah I was more exploratory
exploratory
and when you say a client that that's
more Kink focused
um how do you know how to service a kink
if you don't feel it yourself for
example if you have no interest in feet
and somebody says to you uh I'm a
fantasy I mean I probably sound like the
most clumsy person trying to describe
this one say the word fetishes but yeah
fetishist
um yeah but if someone tells you I like
that and you don't understand why that's
exciting or sexy how do you provide that
service oh the thing is when you see
somebody react to the thing you
understand why it's exactly yeah well at
least I do it's like maybe I don't find
I don't know tables that exciting but if
you see somebody light up about it
you're like oh
that's cute okay
here's a table what about that table
so is the exploration of different Kinks
is it does it take the same sort of
pathway as in seeing their excitement
and then explore me okay for me I love
to see how people react to things and I
love to see how invested they are so I
can be very versatile in what I am happy
to explore
and that also comes For Better or Worse
sometimes it pushes me into areas where
I haven't been so comfortable and I've
had to figure out in my mind whether I
want to navigate it
and then sometimes what would make you
realize uncomfortable when they start to
ask me things about my life okay yes
yeah I because I am quite open I didn't
understand how what I needed to keep to
myself at an early stage I had to learn
that
yeah and that where things would bleed
so you said the stuff that made you feel
uncomfortable was sort of blurring the
lines between you know your private life
and your professional life is there
anything that's ever made you feel
uncomfortable as in have you ever been
with a client where you thought the
fetish was coming from a frightening
place or you know you said earlier about
you didn't want to go off to a hotel
room for your first job with you know
you felt that was potentially unsafe um
and to be isolated in a city I didn't
know it didn't sound like a good idea
sure on a brand new job yeah yeah it
yeah I had a lot of hesitation so I
didn't go with that but the only time
that I've ever felt a little bit
overwhelmed by somebody's desire is a
foot fetishist came in and they were not
interested in power dynamics they were
just enamored with feet and so what
happened was I was sitting on the bed
and they were on the ground and I kick
off my shoes and I put my feet on his
face and then all of a sudden he stands
up and like pushes the feet into his
face and me onto the bed and that was
the first time that somebody had taken
um an assertive action around me
normally it was all just following as I
said but as soon as I said excuse me no
that it ended but it was the only moment
where I realized that okay so there's a
difference between somebody who's there
for the fetish and somebody who's there
for the power Dynamic yeah and I'm more
interested in the power Dynamic yeah
okay and you mentioned earlier about you
know you use tables
um as a I think as a joke but I mean is
it possible that someone could come and
see you like can you have a fetish in
your experience literally about anything
we've all seen documentaries about
people who fall in love with roller
coasters or cars or things like this but
is your experience that it tends to be
the same sort of five topics in
circulation or do people have things
that are very unusual fetish that are
probably you've only seen once or
something like that
I think well we can just go with um
statistics in the house and the most
common things were things to do with uh
anal because uh bodies have prostates
and when they get stimulated it's
apparently very uh engaging
um oh so this is is this this is a male
client being stimulated yeah right okay
and um then another one was
um golden showers people are quite
enamored with and what was the feed good
old feet number one probably yeah really
yeah yeah and I think a lot of people
who wouldn't necessarily consider
themselves kinky
um are also quite enamored by it I'm not
exactly sure why maybe
there's some sort of um erogenous Zone
that we're not uh giving time to anymore
perhaps but
um anything unusual
I don't know if I would use the word
unusual I think very detailed is
probably the things that would stick out
to me the most so if somebody enjoyed a
very particular color on a particular
shirt and they always wanted to see that
kind of color and they wanted to wear it
and they wanted to be teased while they
were wearing it I remember that happened
once so I think that things can become
very particular wow yeah but uh can it
be about anything I don't know how you
would have a a relationship with a
roller coaster
well apparently people do cuddles yes a
little bit difficult yeah and when when
you're in this experience with people
um
do you see yourself like are you also
fighting it you know arousing yeah or
are you having a kind of do you see your
experience more as almost like
you know I guess almost as a
a documentarian you know you're just in
this thing going oh this is interesting
this is what they like I'll do more you
know how does it work for you and the
client together there's so much that's
happening in my head that I'm not even
sure if I can exactly
um go into it but
I mean it takes a lot to run a session
you can plan but ultimately they're
going to react in ways that will be
slightly different so you also have to
be reactive you have a concept of what
you want to do you walk in they react
and I react to their reaction and it's
just an ongoing cycle like this do I
invest in their particular thing that
they're interested in me as a person I
tend to invest in how somebody reacts to
their lives and I am a part of that for
that little while and the more honest
they are and the more raw that they are
the more I want to be there and push it
and I'm not sure exactly what's
happening during that time it's probably
a combination of observation and action
but um but it's like um it's a rush it's
a drug you know
you're getting this thrill-seeking hit
of somebody's focus and investment
for me
so there's something there for you it's
beyond a paid job emotionally yeah
because I am not entirely motivated by
money uh I've always needed that I think
that's where the idealism kind of still
has remnants yeah
have you ever got into a situation with
a client
where you you you know you there was
lies blurred in terms of
connecting with them on a deeper level
yeah and I
that's another thing of mine I feel like
I almost fall in love you know every
time every time in a way you know those
the little little
um rushes that you can get when you meet
somebody that you're attracted to
because I love to see that rawness in
people and day to day people are hiding
that from you I I feel honored I feel
thrilled I feel captivated by it and so
I'm very invested and I've learned how
to feel it for a moment and then step
away from it but it's very very
emotional experience for me hmm
and you so you I know we've we've jumped
around a little bit but you you left the
BDSM dungeon after a year and then after
that were you immediately just uh
basically uh working on your own taking
on individual clients hmm
so during my time at the dungeon I
joined the escort agency
and after the dungeon closed I continued
at the escort agency and I figured out
how to start branding myself as an
independent dominatrix as well and I
kept some of the clients that I had been
seeing and I was advertising I had my
own website I never had my own website
by that stage and I still didn't
understand what social media was I only
did that in the last five years I think
but yeah I started to do really well I
started to do really well and it was
pretty full on until
I mean I I decided not to be full on now
yeah and what kind of clients would you
say in at the beginning there you know
who were your clients
it was really all sorts when I was in
the house it the house had such a
long-standing reputation and a
relatively affordable price point that
it brought
everybody everybody from legal age
up you know and but when I left I
decided to price my sessions not buy
content anymore I was just going to
stick to time which is something that I
learned from the escort agency so my
time was 700 Australian dollars an hour
which was unheard of in Australia back
then for dominatrix
for some reason they were always
Priceless which I never really
understood because for me
there was a physical aspect and like a
schmoozing aspect to the escort work
that was hard work for sure but the
mental
things that you had to run through as a
Dom as a dominatrix it felt like it cost
me a lot more so I did the same rate as
my escort
great and it worked and it worked and it
worked I was fully booked to the point
where I burned out yeah because I just
thought I just I was part of this thing
we had to do three shifts a week at the
at the dungeon at eight hours which is
you know fine because it wasn't like
back to back or whatever all the time
and I guess when you have that
environment you have a receptionist
booking for you all the gear is there
you don't have to clean it you don't
have to do anything in a lot of ways
security Etc but when you're independent
you have to do everything yourself
and
I was using the work schedule but doing
everything myself so it's actually more
and it was just too much
I burned out and after a series of
events
um a partner of mine said well why are
you not just charging more and that's
when I started to edge up and up and up
and up and now I just I I priced myself
out of all of the people who I used to
be able to meet
so do you see during did you see a
change in your clientele based on that
period of time yeah but it's only
because of the price point yeah not
because of me or
so what
I guess it changed from anyone who
wanted to experience that to
to only the people who could afford what
I was asking for them which are a very
small amount of people sadly
and have you
um have you continued to raise your
prices
still I'm open to raising them
now
um that I'm settled here in the UK I
have closed books at the moment
but I might open it up again does close
books means that you're not taking on
clients yeah new ones unless it's like
an exceptional application okay so if
does that mean that with your clients
your clients are continuous clients it's
not people that come to you for one
session and go okay that you know that
that was great they get very invested
wow really so so you see this what's the
longest you've ever seen a client for
in a session or no like a relationship
yeah yes as a relationship I mean I
still see people who I saw in my first
year wow really yeah every time that I'm
back in Sydney they are there waiting so
how long ago is that
11 years 12 years
under these people you know do they tend
to be single people or married people or
all over them all over and do you think
with the married people do you think
that their Partners know about it or
some of them yeah some do some don't and
why do you think
so somebody who's married who's been
married for a long time who comes to see
you
why why do they need to come and see you
instead of experiencing it with their
partner
um why do you go and watch football with
your friends instead of your partner
I mean it's not exactly the same thing
but we have interests that we like to
compartmentalize we have parts of
ourselves that we don't want to show
other people sometimes the partner is
just not interested and why would you
force that on somebody when you have a
relationship that you otherwise are
interested in and during the period you
were developing so you said a minute ago
a partner said to you why don't you put
your prices up so over the time that you
were beginning to do this job you know
did you have partners that you know
unrelated to the job person personal
relationships did you have those at the
same time
many different ones
one lots of different dates lots of
different
partners of varying intensity
yeah and would you
tell them about your job or would you
just see how it goes for a while or what
was your kind of thing there pretty much
from the first
um BDSM dungeon job that I had I started
telling everybody in my day-to-day life
yeah
that was what I would offer up when
people would ask what I did for work
unless I thought people really wouldn't
be able to handle it yeah yeah which is
rare thankfully and how did you know did
you ever have any issues with
relationships based on you know what you
do for a living or not really
people would say that they wouldn't have
issues
and I would always be as transparent as
I could and I would include them on my
thoughts around my work you know just
like any other job but sometimes it
would be turned on me eventually they
might say how could you choose to do
that when you're so old
[Laughter]
or
um I don't think that I think what you
really need is somebody fully in that
world and and not it's just people
projecting uh their
uh lack of awareness of what they're
looking for onto onto me because I I'm
very Frank about who I am what I do I
try to include people you know
very clear they understand about my
clients I even talk about my clients
with them it's
and at the moment I have a few people in
my life who take it on board very well
and don't hold things against me and why
why what's the difference between them
and I guess they live more in a
community and times have shifted they
live more in a community that
is open to speak about where they stand
and their Hang-Ups and be all right with
them whereas I guess maybe 10 years ago
a little bit around there it was not as
much of a conversation and so people had
to suffer on their own and then project
it on the people around them a little
bit more
it's interesting you said earlier that
you suspected it sounds like you really
respect your mum you said that earlier
but you said earlier that you suspected
she'd disown you when you told her but
for you the job was what you would
rather continue the job and have taken
that risk
so it seems like it's a very important
thing for you
I think it was less about the job and
more about the
honesty
because if I had stopped the job I still
would have done it it's okay that makes
sense yeah and so it's about the quality
of a relationship based on
truth as opposed to what I was doing
would there ever be a situation where
someone could say to you whether it's a
partner or family member like I really
really want you to stop doing this and
you would or has it become a really
important part of your personality for
you now I would want to know why why
would you like me to stop if it was I'm
very again open if people are going to
give me
a valid sounding sound argument
that I felt was acceptable then I'm open
to it but I cannot imagine what that
would look like yeah so I think a lot of
people's understanding of what you do is
probably from 50 Shades of Gray ah
um about 100 pages and I couldn't handle
it okay
what why did you stop why did I stop
reading 50 Shades of Gray at the 100
page Mark I really wanted to understand
it was um
just so widely accepted I I was very
curious just to see what was drawing
people in especially because it was
tangential to my world but
I think
I felt like the submissive
didn't have
enough of
um
grounding there was something very uh
wishy-washy about how she was reacting
to the world around her and not enough
of a personality I guess maybe and that
seemed very untrue to me and then also
the way that he was acting was very very
shallow it was very like
you would say something and then this
would happen it just doesn't really work
like that you can't can't just give an
instruction and then somebody's going to
do it you have to build an air of
authority you have to build a trust you
have to build a connection and it was
just so simplistic and basic that it
made me angry okay yeah I thought it was
interesting when that book was released
that suddenly a topic that has been seen
is a nation probably deviant by a lot of
society was suddenly quite accepted you
know Christine gray the main character
and his you know
what he liked to do was suddenly seen as
a very
um almost cool thing what did he like to
do in the end what did he do I don't
know well
um yeah fair I haven't actually read
that I know I saw the first film and I
had the same feeling as you not because
that's my career just because I wasn't
interested in it however uh suddenly
there was a lot of people talking about
domination submission that kind of thing
in a very mainstream way yeah I was just
wondering if you saw that like a poster
if you saw a boom in people interested
in trying that I don't think they would
have been able to afford me
it'll probably started up okay
um but I see it now you know especially
because now I'm actually on social media
yeah I see so many people are so
intrigued by what I do and so many women
ask about doing what I do
really all the time they're so curious
they don't just want to know about the
confidence or the power or the assertion
they want to know how to do what I do
and I I don't necessarily encourage it
because it's a very difficult job in a
very hostile uh Society
um but I'm I'm very I curious as to why
it's of such interest right now why do
you think I mean you have me here
um
well it's a good question uh I suppose
that probably social media and
especially video based social media
where you can share clips of different
things stuff like 50 Shades of Gray I
think has made it mainstream and made
the interest mainstream yeah there's
another very successful Show on Netflix
called The Sinner okay three series of
it but basically the main character in
that is a police detective uh he's
really good detective but in his private
time he goes to a dominatrix because he
has a lot of
um
uh pent up guilt about stuff that
happened in his childhood okay and I
remember when I saw that the thing that
interested me is it better than 50
Shades it is it's well I think so you
might also be angered by that you have
to email us and tell us but I I thought
it was interested about it it was
I was watching it and usually in stuff
like next Netflix dramas the characters
motivations are made very clear to you
right because it's it's a big broad
platform you have to know what's
happening but I couldn't understand what
this guy was getting out of it and
there's things like he'd be he he was he
was punished physically and he was he
was made to feel pain and he'd ask for
forgiveness from the Dominatrix and
things like there's one scene where he'd
be in the supermarket and he was
shopping and he came across her in in
the wild not in there and she kind of
stared at him and tipped his basket over
and I suppose for me you know I'm not
sure how popular that series was but
when I was saw that I became more
interested in that world because it was
clear to me that that's obviously been
written from some sort of experience or
understanding those scenes and clearly
the detective was getting something from
it I can't understand what he was
getting from it so I guess maybe there's
an interest in
why do people you know the impression of
it is that you go to a dungeon somewhere
you get chained up and you get whipped
you know that's the base level of I
think what most people think it is I
don't understand what people get out of
that if it's not some kind of sexual
gratification but you seem to be more
into that world of not the sexual side
but the psychological side well sex is
psychology okay sure I get off on it too
but I mean I can talk about why I go I
think why everyone else goes for so many
different reasons right why I'm there is
because
like I've mentioned people are honest
with me in that space they're vulnerable
with me I get to see how they really are
a lot of the time the artifice of the
day-to-day is really dull for me to
interact with it's not real it's not
engaging I'm not interested but they're
in that space with me I get to really
see a human and it's nice to feel that
connection to something that seems real
to me and aside from that it's such a
challenging environment I have to run it
I have to run somebody's emotional life
for a little while I have to control how
they're going to think how they're going
to move how they're going to think of me
and it's very challenging and it's a
creative exercise so it's it's very
rewarding for me because I'm geared in
the way where I need a lot of creative
psychological stimulation so it works
for me and that does get me off not
always but it comes together to do that
for me and I assume that it's similar
for other people in varying ways on top
of the fact that somebody is just happy
to see you vulnerable and connect with
you which is a nice general feeling that
everybody wants it sounds like part of
what you're describing is like an
honesty so I guess when I'm thinking
back to what you said earlier about one
of the popular ones is golden showers
that might be something people are
embarrassed about and if you have a
partner maybe you're embarrassed to ask
your partner I think so it can be so you
can go to somebody who won't have a
judgment
and you can feel like you can truly be
yourself and say what you want to
receive and they'll
react to that without kind of like
potentially horror and disgust shaming
you unless you want to feel shame right
it gets complicated there I suppose
hey this is Ben Paul Jones we're just
taking a brief break so I can tell you
about one of our sponsors a brand new
six-part podcast from message herd and
podimo who robs the banks he follows
journalist Jake Warren as he sets out to
explore the Stranger Than Fiction tale
of the man who kidnapped a Banksy statue
from the middle of Central London in
broad daylight and held it to Ransom the
ACT would lead to an almost 20-year war
of bad blood relations and legal battles
that are still being waged today and it
all comes down to one man and one
Vendetta but it doesn't end there the
story will take us on a journey through
UK's most subversive subcultures from
art heists and art terrorists to 80s
football hooliganism and the 90s illegal
Rave scene even fetish parties and
throughout it all Jake will be trying to
get a hold of the most Elusive and famed
Anonymous artists in the world
in the new six-part series host Jake
Warren speaks to Tiger King of the art
scene Andy link and those closest to
Banksy himself exposing their two
decade-long Feud and attempting to track
down the world's most elusive Anonymous
artist who robs a Banksy is available
now wherever you get podcasts to hear
the whole series ad free subscribe to
Pottermore UK on Apple podcasts now back
to our episode
have you seen any
shows readily books or films or whatever
they give a accurate representation of
what you do
right
I really enjoyed uh Irene Adler
Sherlock talking about mainstream things
okay yeah that uh the scene where she's
wearing nothing but indecipherable
earrings
uh
and the thought process that goes
between the two of them in it I thought
that that was an interesting thing I
don't think that she's portrayed as a
doll necessarily but the power Dynamic
is quite authentic and the the game that
happens I think was pretty fun to watch
yeah and that reminds me of when you
were talking about like the
mainstreaming of the job a bit and I'm
not sure how I feel about that like if
you had told me that I would be sitting
here like this when I was first starting
I wouldn't have really been able to
conceptualize how that was a thing
uh
there's also an element of threat that
happens with the more exposed that I am
but at the same time if people don't
hear the stories it won't become less
destigmatized which is why I do it right
and so it's this tension I guess people
need to hear it more people maybe need a
shallow entry such as 50 Shades but
where is the danger of that looking
inaccurate where's the danger of that
actually being a detriment I'm not sure
but I don't know just waiting around
trying to figure it out like the rest of
us
so do you have any in terms of
you know you've had quite a long career
so far I guess have you had have you
done any particularly adventurous jobs
or ones that you you remember as
things that you wouldn't do again or
particularly surprising to you in terms
of what you were asked
that I wouldn't do again
I don't know now I have some very long
relationships with my Subs who I'll see
every month for days at a time and oh
days at a time days at a time well
they're involved in my life I know their
families wow
it's pretty intensive it's so know do
you mean you know that families and
they've told you about them or you'll
meet them both wow yeah I'm a friend
usually
but uh but yeah no I quite involved and
their lives have shifted because I've
been in it their minds have shifted how
they approach their work everything so
it gets very involved I feel like
I don't know if I would do this again
it's ended up being wonderful in the
instances that it's come out from
because I guess I tend to just make the
most of what I have and it's been very
profitable also financially
but it it does take over your life yeah
so I don't know if I would go via this
angle again but then another part of me
thinks that maybe there's no other way
because I like that kind of
communication and engagement in that
complexity
so maybe I'm just destined for
for things that maybe aren't
where the boundaries are blurred
you said earlier that you got to a point
in Australia where you decided to charge
700 pounds for an hour of your time at
700 for an hour of your time I mean what
does three days look like or you know
did the ten thousand uh dollars a day
one okay
so I guess if you get to a point where
you're very successful it can be a very
very lucrative industry absolutely
I mean definitely not everyone's going
to get to this stage very very few of us
and it helps that I have a corporate
background and I know how to structure
things
but a negotiate especially but
but yeah it's I I could not have
imagined that this would have been
happening for me I was just following a
joy
and how is a platform like only funds
affected your industry or in fact has it
affected it
I have
and it amuses me but because I manage it
myself a lot of people get other people
to manage it I don't necessarily have so
much time for it it's brought me some
interesting connections but I don't work
it like other people do I'm very happy
that it's provided crazy income streams
for a lot of people but uh I don't know
if it's really impacted me in any way
aside from giving people another Avenue
to connect okay so Vu personally has not
been something that you've seen a huge
well I mean I have had an online thing
even pre-only fans I had a I still have
a website where I do courses and people
learn how to worship my feed or to look
at photos of me you know and rather than
just like looking and jerking off I take
them through a process of what I want
them to feel
and so there's these courses that teach
people how to engage with me
and it's a member's site and that went
mad during covid like it just
it went up like 80 percent in terms of
uh my sign ups but then with that comes
the issue of the adult industry and I
could only be with one payment processor
in that payment processor went bankrupt
and so I only ended up seeing 10 of my
money that year yeah so the online world
is a great opportunity but as long as
Financial systems are
against
um sexuality it will not necessarily be
a stable space that's interesting well I
guess in some ways and only fans has
become
a successful way of doing it because of
yes they also have their own issues so I
mean they are in courts yeah
restructuring being asked to restructure
things a lot that may be the end users
don't see okay you mentioned earlier the
the price in dollars is American dollars
ten thousand American dollars and um I
believe that's around 8 000 British
pounds a day which is an amazing amount
of money but I'm going to once I feel
settled here I might open my books again
and I'll start at a thousand pounds for
an hour
and I might offer a half day for maybe
five
five thousand pounds
and what does a what does a session look
like you know I imagine you know no two
were the same or whatever but you know
like what what are the tools of a
dominatrix what are the things that you
might expect to have to use
um so when you're working independently
it can look a little bit differently
when I worked in the house people would
walk in off the street they would sit in
the waiting room you would meet them
they would ask for specific things you
know limited maybe they had a limited
budget and they would
um expect those things to be pushed into
a session for a certain amount of time
now you can run it however you want when
you're independent you can only accept
sessions that are these three things you
can only do dinners where there's a
power Dynamic it's really up to you how
I run things is I ask them to tell them
to tell me why they want to serve me I
want them to be invested in myself as
opposed to just their Kinks and then
they can tell me a bit about their
experience and what they hope for
and usually I will meet them for uh like
social time like just to get a sense of
who they are and whether they are going
to engage with me how I want to be
engaged with and then we can move into a
space where I'll use the things that
they're interested in to get the
headspace that I want to get off on
yeah so it could be anything they could
be Heavy bondage um lovers which is
probably one of my favorite there's a
lot of leather a lot of gear
um it could be
like somebody who is just simply into
like Chastity and you just toy things
around them not being able to have
control of their own orgasm you know it
could be them just wanting to be a
domestic servitude to you so coming and
cleaning your house while you're there
it could be all sorts yeah and what
about the kind of um you know the the
stereotypical image like whipping people
and things like that does that happen it
does happen but actually a lot of people
are not into uh pain yeah
I understand that yeah yeah I mean pain
and how it transfers to pleasure is
actually quite
linked but there's a lot of things that
people have around their relationship to
pain that helps them to avoid it and so
a lot of people don't ask necessarily to
be whipped to feel torture but
it does get asked and it is a really
nice skill that I enjoy and there is a
lot of catharsis when you receive it and
when you give in but uh does everybody
want it no
and do you ever dislike your clients
will you take on a client if you dislike
them personally
a long term no momentarily I probably
have a moment of dislike for many people
but that's just human interaction sure
you know it's not like I dislike the
person I just don't like what you just
said yeah yeah but that's okay we can
talk about it yeah
okay you seem very uh comfortable with
yourself and what you do is there any
is there anywhere inside that makes you
sometimes think oh I've you know you
know if I could go back I might not have
taken this path or is there any you know
do you do you have any you don't seem to
have any doubts basically about what you
do is that fair to say is an assessment
or not really I think I have a
oh
I'm not 100 sure of anything but that's
the only way that we can be
so I'm very comfortable with that
do I believe that the way that I've
chosen is the right way I believe there
is no right way I believe there are ways
that are going to hurt less people
um but I don't think that
there's a definitive
I think I'm more comfortable in the
unknown than other people so it might
come across as confidence or no doubt
but
it's just that
I understand that we will never know and
I'm okay with that yeah so talking about
your clients like what you've said now
is you've got close books so you're
basically you're not taking on clients
currently you're happy with the ones
that you have but once I get settled in
London I might you feel more settled to
do that again what
I mean it sounds like you charge an
amount of money that really would only
be able to be accessible Now by sort of
high highly paid businessmen or you know
what would be would that be accurate as
a representative there's an
entrepreneurial set who can also afford
it but I don't really like them
[Laughter]
um I guess that when it comes to
corporate structures you have to be able
to
operate within them and understand where
you stand and so there are more skills
around getting along with people I think
that when you are a startup founder
there's a lot more things around being
bullish and negotiation and rather than
clandestinely getting there really
pushing your way through and that kind
of personality set doesn't really sit
very well with I like an Elegance to
your manipulation
not a bullishness on the topic of
manipulation do you find that over your
years of you know exploring people's
psyches
does that bleed into your everyday life
with friendships I mean you must be
getting a raw sense of what humans want
you know because in a lot of times in
relationships you tell people what you
want based on what you think is the do
you know yeah what you think is the
right thing
for someone to hear you want
whereas what you're hearing I guess is
people at the base level being allowed
to ask for anything
so do you feel that when you're in
friendships with people
there's a I don't know a control or a
manipulation or an understanding or an
empathy I don't know how you want to
call it but does what you've learned
through your career bleed into that kind
of relationship I mean everything that
we do bleeds into everything else
um I think that
I've cut a lot of friends over the years
because they were not uh honest enough
and
engaging enough for me I don't think
that there's a sense of obvious
manipulation going on that I worry about
I'd rather not have to think about that
I just want to gently exist and yet be
entertained in my day-to-day
interactions and that's who I gravitate
towards these days it's a lot of other
people who are also working in the
industry but also some who aren't
and how do you so you said that you cut
people who you don't find interesting
basically you know what how do you meet
people these days in terms of
friendships or you know things like that
where do you go to meet people that you
think will give you stimulation they're
not really looking for new friends oh
okay your books are closed on that as
well on clients and friends I'm open to
them right but no I feel very satiated
right now yeah if there was people you
know
listening who were in you said that
people reach out to you interested in
what you do in a lot of women
um
do you encourage people to pursue it as
an Avenue or you know what advice do you
give to people or if people are
listening now and they're thinking
that's something I've always been kind
of fascinated by what would you say I
would say figure out why you're
fascinated by it is it because you enjoy
how you see me communicate and that's
what you want for your life is it
because you want the fashion
because you want the money there are
many ways to get all of these different
things maybe choose a way that isn't
necessarily something that the
government and society says is very
wrong right now unless you think that
you really have you know the guts to
challenge that because I'm not saying
that we should do what Society or the
government necessarily tells us every
time I think that these things should
always be open for discussion at the
very least but whether you have the
fortitude and the support system and
and the space in yourself that will be
challenged
and you're ready for that then you need
to think twice about doing this yeah I
think a lot of the times people enjoy
seeing
this archetype of strength I think that
might be the thing that people are
gravitating towards trying to find a
power for themselves I mean I wouldn't
know how to begin to tell people to do
that I can only tell people how I am and
how it works for me how long do you
think you'll do this for
it's very hard to say because it gives
me such mental challenge
so I don't know if I will want to end it
what do you think you would have done if
you hadn't done this
like I would have been um
I would have followed My Father's
Footsteps into law which wouldn't have
been good for anybody
yeah all right yeah
and I guess um you said you've just
moved to London very recently three days
ago
um
are you seeing people this week
um my main slave is coming to town next
week my main slave wow yeah wow you
haven't used that term before is that
the is that the lingo well for him yes
right yeah and what what would us so you
said a submissive earlier what's the
difference between that and a slave well
people will Define it as submissive can
just be a psychological identity
um slave also but it can have more
connotations rather than submission to a
dominant it can have more connotations
around the being owned being property
yeah and I recently collared him just
kind of like a marriage sort of esque oh
Direction yeah and um and so in the
contract that we have I've used the term
slave and he seemed pretty happy so
we're rolling with that wow so colored
did you say is that is that a term
that's used it's a term that's used yeah
so now he belongs to me okay and you've
signed a contract where he's said that
um do you have do I have the contract no
no I laughed because I realized what an
absurd question it was but do you have a
lot of slaves uh was it an absurd
question well in my world not in your
world yeah yeah
uh do I have a what is a lot more than
one uh yes yes but collared no yeah and
so what's colored is that so color just
like um this is a formal Arrangement now
so it's like a marriage you know yeah
yeah okay and do you have to you can
have for defined periods of time though
according to the contract you negotiate
okay and these are a financial element
to the country there can be if you
wanted to be okay
you have any female
um
I have a few submissives yeah wow okay
yeah all right great I mean we're almost
at the end the thing that I wanted to
ask you I guess is like when you look
back on your life which I mean it sounds
like you've lived in a lot of places and
you've met a lot of different types of
people and you've had a job that not
that many people have had you know
what's your life taught you what's been
the lesson you've learned from your life
lesson what is your lesson
it's me time to think
I mean I haven't had an interesting life
uh like you so I don't know if I I think
I guess what's interesting is when we
meet a lot of people and they sit here
it's like I'm someone like all of us in
this room have probably had very
comparable lives in terms of like
growing up going to University maybe
going abroad for a gap year or something
like that
and I don't think there's much that I
could say that people had listened to on
a podcast and go oh well yeah I see why
fruit picking Australia for six months
has started that fantastic thing it
depends how you saw it for yourself you
know sure yeah I mean and also that's an
incredible opportunity how many people
in the world get to go to another place
to work a totally different life and
come back and be able to feed themselves
I mean it's a luxury
no I totally get that I guess um how
have you done this why
why am I justifying why I'm not the
subject of the podcast
I'm not even going to justify it you
know people are now going to read a
podcast title middle-aged white Dad
I think you know International I don't
want to get too far away from it but I
am very interested to know what dads
think about their lives we don't hear
about it enough I think anyway back to
me well I can tell you what Nursery dads
think about their lives they all stand
out the front waiting for their kids and
pretend they're having a nice chat but
compete over how far up the scale their
child is and how fast developing that's
what Nursery does think okay okay and
then we could go into why that is but we
won't okay
what do I think that I've learned from
my life
ah that I know nothing and so I might as
well enjoy it
I think maybe that will change
do you see yourself uh the thing that
you're doing are you bringing pleasure
to other people or are you doing
something for yourself do you think
definitely both
hmm
look either it's been um brilliant to
have you on it's been really interesting
thank you and it's great to hear this
kind of like articulate description of a
world I don't think we often get a
window into I also think it's really
interesting to have a window into it
from a completely positive side because
I think often a lot of times when these
kind of things are reported on they're
done so with a pre-held bias that it
must be a negative thing I think it's
interesting to hear it discussed as I
mean you say it was a positive
experience
I would say it's a positive experience
because in general I tend to take
positive things out of life
but it's come with a lot of challenge
but I enjoy challenge it comes with a
lot of toil I'm somewhat of a masochist
as alongside my sadism you know I really
enjoy the experience of life no matter
how much pain I sometimes feel I enjoy
it I'm the weird person who doesn't have
a medicine cabinet
that's true that's
that's feeling sick I enjoy feeling I
enjoy feeling I enjoy being alive yeah
so I'm probably the wrong person to ask
if you're going to ask for a negative
experience you can find something
interesting in almost everything
fascinating thank you so much for coming
in
and I said there is no amount of money
that you could pay me
but if I had done it and done it well I
could have progressed to a horse you
know I love how off topic you go
it's just gold
oh my gosh